but then there is also you know the
doxer the what the doxer what is that
that is the story The the formal story
that you're not allowed to
[Music]
question I do think it's a problem that
some people have this monolithic
understanding of the science including
scientists themselves and uh we've seen
how badly that that served us I think
during during the co
during the pandemic
because it was used it was weaponized if
you like the idea of there being the
science or a consensus a model that
really explained everything and that
there could be that could never be
challenged that was not the situation of
Co we had two competing models so in one
model was which is very straightforward
what we call an SS model which uh
straightforward mathematical simple
compartmental models um where people are
categorized being either susceptible
infected recovered you just have flows
between them very simple model with some
seasonality thrown in would explain the
patterns of coid pretty much anywhere in
that case what's really driving
everything is the buildup of immunity
and the loss of immunity and also the SE
the fact the transmissibility of the
pathogen is uh depends on the season so
just those ingredients alone can explain
all of Co but of course those who
believed that lockdown um and social
distancing and whatnot were the real
drivers of the Dynamics also proposed a
model completely you know so internally
consistent and of equal value um saying
that no the reason why uh cases declined
in the United Kingdom in May 2020 was
because we locked down so how do you
tell them apart well you can't until you
do an experiment that experiment was
done which is a year later when these
measures were lifted under one model the
one where lockdown worked you would have
seen an explosion of cases the other
model which is simple simply explained
by the standard traditional models in
which immunity plays the main part you
wouldn't see an explosion in cases so we
had to wait to do that experiment that
to discriminate between these two
alternative hypotheses which were of
equal value up to that point so we did
have two competing hypotheses we also
had a problem in that there was also an
establishment which preferred not to
allow one of the hypotheses in my
opinion the correct one to to be um disc
put on the table it's interesting in
your case with Co we had a real chance
to put it to the test right this is so
the problem for cosmology is you
generally don't have the problem problem
too like you don't have uh the luxury of
being able to create experiments you're
interpreting signs in the sky and you're
observing and you're trying to bring
those measurements into some framework
in physics you have repeatable
experiments under control conditions uh
in the case of coid we had an experiment
that where we were all guinea pigs but I
believe I don't know if you want to
State the conclusion from uh from this
experiment there a clearly one
hypothesis over the other that would
interest me no well I'm biased but yes I
I think that by and large we did not see
the sort of explosion that would go with
um the assumption that lockdowns as they
were um affected in the UK for example
that they stopped the spread that the
spread was undoubtedly stopped by the
acquisition and loss of immunity and
seasonal factors but is there now based
on what we have seen from that is there
a growing agreement ment in your
community about this is the actual
conclusion not no but that's a whole
other topic that's a whole other topic
well you going to say something well but
the the comparative method could also
apply what did other countries do and
when did they close down when did they
reopen most of these European countries
reopen much sooner than America and they
did fine they did not have a huge Spike
all right so that should count as data
it it all does
yeah but then there is also you know the
doxer the what the doxer what is that
that is the story The the formal story
that that you're not allowed to question
but now we're string outside science so
let's the politicization of science like
the lab leak hypothesis that always
seemed like a reasonable hypothesis with
the zentic hyp the origins of Co but
then it got shut down you can't talk
about that that's a crazy conspiracy
theory and I never thought it was no I
don't think it is a crazy Theory at the
same time I personally don't think it
was a lab leak but I think the shutting
down of it I also don't think it came
out sprung out of a bowl of Pangolin
chop sewy in the market but anyway I
think it came from the wild and it was
circulating already for a tough I mean
the most parsimonious explanation to
continue watching this video click the
link in the top left or in the
description below or visit a.tv for more
debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas